all right let's change gears a little
bit let me ask you a question do any of
you believe that joe biden is running
for reelection in 2024 i mean do any of
you think that he is i don't and this is
my opinion and i know that
it's considered sometimes inappropriate
to say well if he hasn't said he isn't
running david sir you shouldn't really
be saying it because you might
demoralize i give you my opinion on this
show my opinion is there is no sign
whatsoever that joe biden is running for
reelection in 2024. kamala harris
recently had to walk back a statement
she made kamala harris during an
interview said joe biden is running
and i will be his running mate
and the next day she had to back it up
and say well actually uh joe biden
intends to run and when you keep hearing
intends to run
and they go beyond it and say he's
running and then they've got to back it
up and say that what i meant was he
intends to run not that he is running
it points to me that there is no way joe
biden is running for reelection so let's
look at a couple of clips here's the
first one this was an interview that
vice president kamala harris gave to cnn
and she sounded very definitive early
last week take a look joe biden is
running for reelection and i will be his
ticket mate wow
full stop close stop right sounding
incredibly confident and yet
then she had to back it up
from the la times vice president harris
says biden intends to run for
re-election this was two days later vice
president kamala harris created new
uncertainty wednesday about president
biden's intentions to run in 2024
pulling back from the definitive
statement she made earlier in the week
the president intends to run
and if he does
i will be his ticketmate
we will run
together we will run together that is
not the confident statement that she
made on monday we have seen this
language before you might remember that
many times when former white house press
secretary jensaki was asked
is joe biden running for reelection
because he hasn't declared his candidacy
she would go with this phrase intends to
run here's just one example of that
there was another round of stories over
the weekend about the political fate of
the president and the vice president
and who might run in 2024
and it quotes a lot of
other democrats or people who work for
them
what is the white house's message to
those democrats
the white house's message is we're
focused right now on what the american
people elected the president to do less
about just over a year ago which is to
get covet under control to put people
back to work
and to help give people some breathing
room and we hope other people keep their
focus on that as well did they knock it
off
is that speculation the president has
every intention of running for
reelection so that's the other message
for them every intention there is an
intent to run for re-election
guys i don't think joe biden's running
and we very rarely on this program talk
about an election that's not the next
one the next one is in
uh four in four months
that's the one we would normally
exclusively be talking about we have a
very different situation right now where
i believe there is every sign that joe
biden is not going to run for
re-election he would be 82 at the time
of the next term and it's just not
seeming to me like he's going to run his
vice president kamala harris who would
often be the natural person to run if it
is not the president himself is
extraordinarily unpopular kamala harris
as of right now that could change but
right now she's very unpopular and there
are increased whisperings
that donald trump will soon be declaring
his candidacy for 2024.
my belief at this point is
joe biden if he is not going to run
should announce it sooner than later
probably not before the november
election it seems to me that it would be
more prudent to wait until the midterms
and then for joe biden to relatively
quickly say i am not going to run for
re-election why
if donald trump does declare or he
declares that he's not running and it's
there's a focus on desantis as their
increasingly is or whatever
it seems like a bad
recipe
to have an aggressive republican
candidate who has announced they are
running
out there attacking biden
and biden not planning to run but not
saying he isn't planning to run and
democrats just will be weakened and
weakened and by the time democrats have
a nominee by the time joe biden says i'm
not running by the time it gets sorted
out
whoever is the strongest de facto
candidate on the republican side has had
months if not years to prop themselves
up and to beat down on the democratic
party and whoever uh eventually intends
to run
so
unfortunately there's a bit of a
reactive element where
if trump says he's running or if trump
says he's not and there are rumors he
may do this soon
i believe that is bad for whoever is the
eventual nominee be it joe biden or not
and so if biden is not running my belief
is he should make that known sooner than
later ideally not before the midterms
let me know your thoughts whether you
agree or disagree i want to hear from
you you can find me on twitter at
dpakman and we'll be back right after
this
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10-year warranty
you can try the mattress risk-free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will for a limited time
helix is offering up to three hundred
and fifty dollars off all mattress
orders plus two free pillows at helix
sleep dot com slash pacman it's the
biggest discount they've ever offered
the link is down below